um
uh
uh
wait
so
okay
okay
yes
foreign
so
doc thanks
appreciate it
listen you got your card
all right
brandon how are you can you hear me
yes sir thank you good you have it pal
and dr tompkins how are you doing
fine thank you sir good
well look uh let me get started here i
want to say good afternoon everybody
this is a
week i
signed in law the bipartisan government
funding bill demonstrating again that
the american people
that
democrats and republican independents
can come together and do some big things
this bill includes something i've
believed in for a long long time
arpa h an advanced research project
agency for health
it's based as dr
tompkins knows is based on
the defense department's advanced
research project agency that has led for
break lead breakthroughs
and technologies to protect our security
everything from the internet to gps and
so much more
rph will have a singular purpose to
drive breakthroughs
in biomedicine to prevent detect and
treat diseases including cancer
alzheimer's and diabetes i want to thank
the bipartisan members of the house and
senate who are working so hard to get
this done senator patrick leahy pat
patty murphy roy blunt richard burr
representatives
representatives anna eschew rosa de
laura frank pallone
diane degette fred upton
like darpa arpa h will pursue ideas that
break the mold on how we normally
support fundamental research and
commercial products in this country
ideas so bold no one else not even the
private sector is willing to to to give
them a chance or to
sink a lot of money into trying to solve
ideas so audacious that people say
it just might work only if only if we
could try
well we're about to try in a big way
and that's what this meeting is about
because
h is modeled after darpa and i've asked
the darpa director stephanie tompkins
to speak about the promise of arpa-h in
fact we're going to hear
from a patient who benefit from darpa
research and enabled him to use a
prosthetic arm that moves but also
provides a sense of touch which she
couldn't do before we couldn't do before
imagine losing your arm in a war or an
accident and regaining the ability to
feel to actually feel what it's like to
hold the hand of a spouse or a child
it's remarkable we'll also hear from dr
uh
i'm going to mispronounce
well just dr nelson
who leads the white house office on
science and technology my science
advisor dr francis collins to talk about
how to ensure arpa h's
harnesses the powers and possibilities
of science and technology to benefit all
of america
to focus on equity because every
american should have access to
cutting-edge healthcare and innovations
and to make it impossible
make the impossible possible and you've
heard me say over and over again
america can be defined by a single word
possibilities
i'm going to stop there so we can get
this meeting started and then i'm going
to turn to dr nelson so
uh let me uh again dr nelson
[Music]
mr
[Music]
russia mr president
you